every video game should be awesome but
we know that's just not the case
so we'll usually just settle for video
games at least being functional
unfortunately many video games ship with
glitches that make them impossible or
just outright ridiculous here are a few
bugs that destroyed perfectly good games
and should have sent their programmers
looking for new work duck DUP it's a
simple game about hunting delicious
birds for sport but even Nintendo's duck
hunt was published with a gamebreaking
glitch if you can endure your snickering
dog for 99 levels of bird murdering fun
that's it there's nothing there your
reward is round zero a sour purgatory
where immortal birds disappear and
reappear at random and the game ends
proving that there's no reward for duck
genocide in real life or in Nintendo now
for the real challenge loading those
thousands of dark corpses into your
pickup truck the missing Pokemon in the
olden days there were only 151 Pokemon
and that was good enough because of
programming limitations the original
Game Boy games left spots for 256
different encounters in pokemon red &
blue 151 slots were filled with pokemon
others with trainers and 39 spots were
left empty if you follow a specific
sequence of actions you'll encounter the
massive code called missing number and
be able to capture it but doing so can
cause game breaking errors in other
parts of your save sometimes you
shouldn't catch him on crappy holidays
back in the day Sony's video game
magazine PlayStation underground would
regularly send out preview discs to the
subscribers but around Christmas 2004
PlayStation 2 owners were in for a
pretty terrible surprise
unfortunately the PlayStation
underground holiday 2004 demo disc would
destroy the save data on any
memory cards still plugged into its
system regardless of the game
Sony sent out warnings but it was too
late dark don't come back
gamers lost thousands of hours of play
time data when their memory cards were
blanked out for many players those hours
had been invested in the recently
shipped grand theft auto san andreas
just think of all of those unmerged
civilians still walking around
boss loss bubble bubble revolution on
the Nintendo DS includes one of the
dumbest bugs ever released what should
have been a simple remake of a hundred
level game was accidentally cut short at
level 30 for no other reason than the
programmers forgot to put in a boss
because the boss battle was an essential
trigger to move on to level 31 the game
was simply unbeatable code Buster's
eventually replaced the bugged cards but
they'll never live down the unmitigated
done sory of a mistake object over load
the massive glitch found in the Elder
Scrolls 4 Shivering Isles is also pretty
simple if you play too much of this
oblivion expansion your game will crash
because of a programming issue the pc
version of the expansion would freeze
once its memory was full of background
data this was because the data wasn't
being recycled when it was no longer in
use
but there's the push data fix after
about a month and the irony that a game
expansion called Shivering Isles had
severe freezing issues was lost on no
one don't change a thing the Soul
Calibur series includes a pretty solid
string of fighting games but a terrible
bug in the third installment nearly
derailed the whole thing for PlayStation
2 users the error doesn't manifest as a
part of the game itself but rather when
players attempt to change move copy or
delete any of their older save data
associated with any of their games
the glitch can potentially destroy or
corrupt all of the data on a player's
memory guard or gamers have been able to
figure out workarounds like saving on a
separate memory card for just this one
game amount of jiggle physics is worth
losing all of your games infinitely easy
players may furiously debate whether or
not the introduction of infinite spin to
Tetris worlds was a glitch or not but is
game breaking enough to be considered a
travesty either way by repeatedly
hitting the spin button a player can
keep a Tetris piece in the air
indefinitely which is a totally cheap
move the official tetris company
unconvincingly denies the inclusion of
this cheater move is a glitch but the
easy spin was made optional in
subsequent games but still it's not the
worst thing to ever happen to tetris
that credit goes to appearing in pixels
no signal Batman has it tough enough but
in batman dark tomorrow he's pretty much
doomed from the start the only real way
to beat villain Rachele ghoul is to find
a signal device hidden somewhere except
the game never tells you where it is or
that it even exists and while it's one
of the most Kafka esque video game
twists of all time no one plays video
games to feel like a giant helpless bug
and making a game with no Direction
about how to actually win is a pretty
big bug indeed face-off
Ubisoft should have taken it's time to
give Assassin's Creed unity a proper
debut as the first next-gen exclusive of
the series instead it was rushed out the
door with a plethora of glitches
clipping issues and animation hiccups
which is a bad look considering the
countless number of assassin creed
titles before it even after the patches
unity still has more bugs than the
courtesans of Paris the worst offense a
glitch during cutscenes that causes
faces to disappear resulting in
horrifying grotesque village of hair
eigvals teeth and gums floating above
character's clothes we hope someone at
Ubisoft got the guillotine for deciding
to ship this ugly unfinished product
every part of Superman 64 when a game
starts out by covering everything in a
kryptonite fog because it can't render
its own graphics you know you're off to
a bad start regarded as one of the worst
games of all time Superman's the new
adventures found an audience among small
stupid children
but it's so full of game crushing
glitches that it's considered unplayable
here's the catch though the whole game
takes place in a virtual reality
programmed by Lex Luthor
so maybe Lex is just a really really
terrible programmer from that
perspective this is actually the most
clever game of all time thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which video game bugs
drove you crazy